I mean uh what do we got timewise
we're over an hour yeah no we're long
you seemed like you're tired and you
know what you're gonna finish it okay I
will
I'm with you Theo I'm pretty tired yeah
you seem gonna tar down another you're
ill and so don't want to waste too much
your time yeah um it's like Downton
Abbey I gotta be up at 5:00 in the mine
do you for what Hawaii you won't know
why yeah are you being on a space movie
yeah are you really yeah you just sent
me a bullet today did they offer you
something no he said that they he tried
to get me a spot in it oh that wouldn't
it on dude easy you're gonna be in a
congrats just one scene I'm a hotel
clerk huh hotel clerk yeah well honestly
um let's talk about David Spade for a
second is um give me a hat he is
honestly that dude that dude let's be
honest dude that dude is it me or is he
truly one of the nicest people you'll
meet nice man I honestly like as soon as
I was introduced to him in like you know
equal footing like I didn't meet him you
know at SNL you know I met him since he
was came to the comedy store yeah and
dude he's only just been so [ __ ] nice
and helpful yeah in a kind guy that cool
yeah he's nice he's friendly he is yeah
he loved to just laugh he liked that fun
he likes his Instagram stories really
funny till he wants the bachelor yeah
yeah and he invited me every other watch
The Bachelor one time over there yeah
yeah it was very fun of just me sitting
on the couch and him sitting behind me
in a chair in The Bachelor do I fats
weird Hollywood [ __ ] like that too like
one time I know Russell Brand a little
bit mm-hmm and he goes hello come over
with you and Stephen will do some
meditation and they had one of those big
Yogi's right and I was little I've never
met it I don't know I don't do yoga or
meant it but there was candles I was in
a room with Russell and Stevo and me and
we're like in some ball to the lady
Russell who Russell Brown Russell Brand
Oh Russell Brand I think you talking
about that Russell Brown Joe Russell
[ __ ] his Russell Brown guy then when to
this rival High School in our town they
used to put some say play halfback er
yeah running back yeah like how the [ __ ]
you know Russell Brown but they now
[ __ ] this Tito some worlds don't fit
together yeah yeah but you know in your
head even listen to me in your [ __ ]
head
yeah even if you heard Russell Brown
right normal people got there's no way
so they would cut that out and they go
he's probably thinking of a Russell
Brand that's what you're saying right
but in your [ __ ] up head
you went they know each other sleepy ass
Kingdom bro
come over here [ __ ] half awake
whatever is a deal this [ __ ] blood
donor over here propping the rest of you
guys dudes [ __ ] you got big whites of
your home the [ __ ] dicks down I get
it they're going on I know I Dark
Kingdom but I always say something right
now dude think think
for once in your life okay alright
that's all I want you to do to look at
me right now man yeah I'm thinking right
now oh I think you've had too many
[ __ ] net ah dude nachos but dude this
brand right here
can we get sponsored by Ben Ben Ben
feels no this is the best well I go to
the store just to get these rice and
beans rice and beans bro yeah well I
like chips are made out of damn chips
bro yeah yeah I'm like somebody's a
bait-and-switch oh it's nachos guess
what's it [ __ ] rice and beans [ __ ]
you bruh yeah you know I want the real
[ __ ] so anyway this week when does this
come out next week Oh next week [ __ ]
well Thursday in Houston didn't sell out
but I will tell you guys what's the week
after ah the week after is March 6th 7th
and March 7th I'm at the I'm in Boston
and I'm in Medford actually at the
cheval your theater and then March 8th
I'm in at the Wilbur and Borgata on the
9th
what Wilbur theater and out in Boston
yeah I thought that once you did and
then San Jose March 21st 22nd and 23rd
that's a good room too I'm excited I'm
killing it you know does San Jose oh my
god you're gonna kill it you're gonna
love it there it's so much fun it's a
great hotel it's a great [ __ ] comic
I've been do go there for 20 years I've
[ __ ] place it's the best in you're
gonna love it
Wow there's an English stir that runs it
an English student dude English dude
that's another thing British man stop I
said English dude right you heard
student you should have crossed that on
your head dude he didn't say that
probably said dude you'd like to give
you the benefit of the doubt but I'll
say this man I love tired my favorite
really yeah yeah I'm thinking about
[ __ ] binds for cigarettes man you
feel me oh yeah you're only on day two
you need to get home we need to get this
yeah where they are anyway